david gray war alles schaut gegenwärtig
gebannt in die usa wo das government
shutdown alles blockiert es gibt einige
die befürchten die staatspleite in den
usa
was würde passieren wenn es dazu käme
das weiß niemand so richtig gut möglich
dass es nicht so schlimm wäre die manche
prophezeien
denn eine regierung kann nicht wirklich
pleite machen
us-staatsanleihen sind das einzige
worauf sich die leute verlassen können
da sie relativ stabil sind so wird das
hier gesehen
die schuldenlast ist ja wirklich
beeindruckend in vielen ländern in den
usa beträgt gegenwärtig über 16
millionen dollar gesehen einen aber eine
art ticker hier das ist vom us
finanzdepartement wir sehen die die
zahlen durchlaufen wie die schulden in
jeder minute größer werden
sie sagen staatsschulden seien meistens
vor allem kriegsschulden dem dienen
wollen wir die schulden eigentlich ja
die staatsschulden der usa sind
ursprünglich schulden aus dem revolution
screen alle modernen regierungen sind
verschuldet und meistens sind es
kriegsschulden in den usa waren das die
ersten schulden und das ist bis heute so
die zahlen dort stimmen übrigens nicht
sie geben nur etwa die hälfte der
wirklichen verteidigungsausgaben an
sogar weniger als die hälfte
denn sie fälschen die buchhaltung aber
gesamthaft entspricht es in etwa den
staatsschulden aber alle debatten
rasieren auf falschen prämissen als ob
geld ein stoff wäre den man irgendwo
bekommt und besitzt oder nicht besetzt
und wenn zu viel davon ausgeliehen wird
könnte das eine art deflation auslösen
aber keiner weiß so richtig welche
folgen ein defizit haben könnte und wenn
das die sorge der regierung ist warum
druckt dann die us-notenbank
unbeschränkt geld damit löst sie eine
inflation aus trotzdem drückt sie so
viel geld wie möglich nach dem prinzip
der quantitativen lockerung und es hat
trotzdem keine folgen für die inflation
schon mitten im thema dem thema der
schulen sie haben ein buch geschrieben
daytrader überschulden die ersten 5000
jahre sie haben damit einen bestseller
gelandet wurden in den fonds rund um den
globus fast schon glorreich gesprochen
ich habe mich entschieden dieses buch zu
schreiben weil ich realisiert hatte dass
das thema alle aspekte unserer existenz
einschließt man denke nur an die
internationalen beziehungen an moderne
staaten die ihre defizite finanzieren
müssen an die konsolen wirtschaft die
eine schuldenwirtschaft ist also uns
herum ist davon betroffen und ich war
höchst erstaunt zu entdecken dass noch
niemand die geschichte der schulden
geschrieben hat sie finden die
geschichte des automobils des studiums
oder der knöpfe aber niemand hat die
geschichte der schulden geschrieben als
ich zu recherchieren begann entdeckte
ich dass der grund vielleicht darin
liegt dass man einen skandal aufdeckte
wenn man beschreibt was sich alles
ereignet hat etwas kam sehr klar heraus
wir können die geschichte der schulden
nicht verstehen ohne die geschichte des
geldes eine schuld ist ein versprechen
das entgelt präzise bezeichnet werden
kann
doch wenn wir uns schuld so ansehen dann
bekommt auch das geld ein anderes
gesicht
wir haben gelernt dass das geld wegen
der unannehmlichkeiten des tauschhandels
geschaffen botter 1 tauschte man dinge
und das schaffte jene probleme welche
die ökonomen als die doppelte koinzidenz
der tausch pläne bezeichnete
ich biete 25 hühner für diese kuh aber
es kommt kein handel zustande weil sie
meine hühner nicht wollen und darum
erfand mir das geld und seitdem ins netz
das geschrieben hat sind die
anthropologen weltweit auf der suche
nach völkern die noch tauschen
doch es ließen sich keine beweise für
die these finden dennoch der es
gelegentlich doch tun dann mit fremden
die sie nie mehr sehen werden niemals
aber mit nachbarn
dafür gibt es gute gründe
wenn sie mit nachbarn handeln und der
nachbar hat gerade nicht hat sie
brauchen aber etwas das sie später
wollen dann entsteht schon die grundlage
für kredite und schulden zwischen den
gliedern der gesellschaft nun stellt
sich die frage wie der begriff von
schuld oder verpflichtung zu etwas
messbaren wert leider stellt sich diese
frage fast unvermeidlich in situationen
von realer oder potenzieller gewalt etwa
bei rechtsstreitigkeiten 25 stück von
diesem ist gleich einem stück von dem
das ist das wesen von geld zu berechnen
dass die menge von etwas gleich viel
bedeutet wie die menge von etwas anderem
viele ersatzansprüche entstehen etwa
wenn jemand verletzt oder getötet wird
und eine blutfehde vermieden werden soll
oder wenn man alle möglichen geschenke
gemacht hat und diese nicht dem
entsprechen was erwartet wird
wenn alle sehr zornig sind und gewalt
ausbrechen könnte dann bis in die leute
genau was sie wollen wenn sie nicht
genau das haben was der kodex lang
müssen sie etwas von exakt gleichem wert
aufbringung dieser link zwischen geld
und gewalt zieht sich durch die
geschichte der menschheit
nun um ein beispiel zu geben
ich glaube dass er wähnte ich noch nicht
ein beispiel ist das aufkommen der
münzprägung das kreditwesen ist zwar
viel älter also das physische geld 2000
jahre älter oder mehr
aber als die menschen die münzprägung
einführen und diente dies hauptsächlich
der bezahlung von soldaten
das geschah etwa zur gleichen zeit im
östlichen mittelmeer in griechenland in
der heutigen türkei in nordindien und
notieren
es ging immer ums gleiche unzählige
kleine staaten und königreich geführten
krieg und es entstanden eine klasse von
berufs kriegern und stehende diese
berufs krieger mussten natürlich
besoldet werden und geld die physische
münzen wurde im wesentlichen erfunden
als eine technologie die kriegsführung
es ist eines der großen geheimnisse der
wirtschaftsgeschichte hätte adams mit
recht und das geld entstünde spontan aus
den bedürfnissen des handels und gold
und silber würden von selbst und ohne
staaten aus dazutun zu geld warum hätten
dann königer überhaupt steuern in gold
nach oben
wozu das gold mit dem eigenen bildnis
prägen es ausgeben und sagen allem ist
es zurückgeben
die könige haben die gold- und
silberminen ausgebeutet und hatten so
viel geld wie sie wollen
aber es macht durchaus sinn märkte zu
schaffen als ein mittel seine truppen zu
versorgen das große problem bei alle
diese leute zu verpflegen wenn 50.000
mann an einem ort stationiert sind
werden sie in kürze alles essbare in
erreichbarer distanz verzehren
es braucht eine weitere armee nur zur
verpflegung der erste es braucht den
schlauen drehten die könige anmeldung
soldaten bekommt man nicht auf kredit
aber sie nehmen gerne ein paar gold und
silber stücke und so prägt der könig
münzen mit seinem bild gibt sie in
soldaten und sagt jeder im königreich
muss mir eine dieser münzen zurückgeben
so erreicht man dass die ganze
bevölkerung die soldaten versorgt ihre
thesen sind ja ziemlich steile sie
wollen tatsächlich alles auf den kopf
stellen und wenn man einen wirtschafts
buch aufschlägt dann wird man immer die
thesen finden die sie angreifen aber ihr
buch ist er nicht nur einen einblick
über die geschichten der schulden obwohl
sie aus ethnologe auch davon eigentlich
ausgehen diese geschichte schreiben in
mesopotamien beginnen und bis in die
heutige zeit gehen aber sie stellen auch
thesen auf bezüglich der frage wie mit
diesen schulden umzugehen haben und eine
ihrer thesen ist ja sehr überraschend
schulden muss man nicht zurückzahlen
geht das wirklich für alle nun selbst
die gängige wirtschaftstheorie sagt dass
es die möglichkeit der schulden verzugs
geben muss denn die profite die ein
kreditgeber erwirtschaftet sollten die
entschädigung für das eingehen von
risiken seien gibt es kein risiko gibt
es auch keine rechtfertigung für den
profit also selbst die einfache
ökonomische logik impliziert wenn jedes
darlehen garantiert zurückbezahlt wird
wo bleibt dann der anreiz geld in die
eigentliche produktive investition zu
lenken was er die existenzberechtigung
für finanzinstitute sein sollte aber in
einem erweiterten sinn möchte ich darauf
hinweisen dass eine schuld nur ein
versprechen ist sie hat keinen höheren
oder geringeren moralischen stellenwert
als jedes andere versprechen wir
behandeln sie als etwas absolutes andere
versprechen sind verhandelbar
schulden sind es absolut nicht aber
gerade wenn sie sagen es ist wie ein
versprechen also sie daten ja auch sie
sie schätzen das nicht dass man
sozusagen die moralische dimension der
schulden zusammen nimmt mit der
monetären mit dem materiellen dimension
der schuld sondern sie sagen das sollten
liegen immer vergessen die sollten die
moral rausnehmen aus dieser rede von
schulden
andererseits könnte man doch sagen na ja
es ist doch eben wie ein versprechen und
wenn man versprechen bauern bricht dann
zerbricht irgendwie auch das vertrauen
und teilen
durchaus ich sage nicht dass schulden
nach belieben ignoriert werden sollen
das hat schon jesus gesagt ich sage
schulden sollten nicht anders als jedes
andere versprechen behandelt werden
ich möchte das so umschreiben eine
schuld ist ein versprechen das
korrumpiert wurde durch eine kombination
von mathematik und gewalt sie ist ein
versprechen das genau gemessen werden
kann
sie ist ein versprechen das mit zwang
eingetrieben werden kann und wird damit
unpersönlich und übertragbar
der geldbetrag ist eine übertragbare
schuld im unterschied zu anderen
versprechen
doch obschon man annehmen könnte ein
solches versprechen sei weniger heilig
als ein persönliches versprechen dass
man jemandem gibt wird das heiliger
gehalten sein moralische stellenwert ist
so stark dass es jedes andere
versprechen moralische in den schatten
stellt ich bringe gerne das beispiel von
den politikern
wir leben in demokratien und die
politiker machen versprechungen um
gewählt zu viele politiker versprechen
ein unentgeltliches bildungs und
gesundheitswesen und sobald sie gewählt
sind heißt es wir können uns das nicht
leisten weil wir unsere schulden
bezahlen müssen
warum finden wir jetzt normal dass das
versprechen einem kreditgeber eine
schuld mit zinsen zurück zu geben nicht
verhandelbar ist während versprechen dem
wähler gegenüber nur gemacht sind um
gebrochen zu werden versprechen wirklich
ernst gemeint sondern wollte vor allem
gewählt werden jetzt noch einmal im
persönlichen umfeld schauen
das ist auch ein problem sie möchten
sich gerne etwas kaufen sie leihen sich
geld von jemanden wann können sie nicht
einfach sagen ich muss nicht
zurückbezahlen
und normalerweise tut man das auch nicht
aber was ich sagen will ist das ein
versprechen ums geld nicht anders
gewertet werden sollte als irgendein
anderes versprechen
klar wollen sie bezahlen und ihr
versprechen halten unsere gesellschaft
selber ist auf eine art eine ansammlung
von versprechen die wir einander geben
infrage stelle ich die art wie wir
gewisse versprechen als absolut
behandeln und andere nicht und besonders
dass wir sie nur dann als absolut
behandeln wenn sie zwischen bestimmten
menschen stattfinden zwischen
gleichgestellten werden schulden immer
verhandelt sowohl zwischen gewöhnlichen
menschen als auch zwischen reichen und
mächtigen im buch nenne ich das den
kommunismus der reichen
reiche leute können unglaublich viel
verständnis aufbringe für andere reiche
heute die probleme haben manchmal
treiben sie ihre spielchen wie goldman
sachs gegen lehman brothers aber wenn
sie glauben dass sie stand als solcher
bedroht ist sind plötzlich alle schulden
erlassen
und niemand findet dass donald trump
schlechter ist als jede andere reiche
nur weil er mit seinem bankrott alle
seine schulden abgeschüttelt hat bei
konzernen wie der american insurance
group gingen billionen von dollar den
bach runter weil sie sonst in
schwierigkeiten gekommen wären aber
einem hypothekarschuldner wird nichts
verziehen und das ist von bedeutung denn
der kleine schuldner fliegt aus seinem
zuhause
während eine versicherung niemals auf
der straße steht da wird natürlich ein
rettungsschirm aufgespannt
wir beobachten dass wenn eine schuld ein
versprechen ist zwischen gleichen dann
wird es behandelt wie jedes andere
versprechen
es ist verhandelbar wenn ich ihnen
versprechen dass ich sie morgen 5 uhr
auf der straße treffen werde und meine
mutter stirbt dann kann ich das sicher
nicht einhalten
geht es freilich um einen geldbetrag
dann gibt es nichts zu verhandeln
solange es um eine schuld eines armen
gegenüber einem reichen geht und der
arme ist damit einverstanden dass ist
eine heilige pflicht und
selbstverständlich gibt es da nichts zu
verhandeln
hingegen werden schulden des reichen
gegenüber dem armen durchaus als
verhandelbar betrachtet in den usa wird
dauernd nach wegen gesucht wie man die
soziale sicherheit an kratzen könnte
da geht es jetzt um eine schuld
gegenüber dem einfachen bürger
das gleiche geschieht in der
kreativwirtschaft ich selbst arbeite als
schriftsteller und akademiker angenehm
an meinem akademiker job ist dass es nie
heißt man hätte vergessen dich zu
bezahlen als schriftsteller künstler
oder musiker geschieht das automatisch
dass sie ihr geld nicht bekommen da geht
die schuld nicht als heiliges
versprechen dimension ihres berufslebens
ausgelassen sie sind nämlich nicht nur
akademiker und schriftsteller sondern
sie sind auch ein aktives die sind der
intellektuelle kopf der occupy-bewegung
ob sie es mögen oder nicht zu werden so
oft verkauft
was bedeutet ihnen die occupy bewegung
es ist interessant wie ich da
hineingeraten bin mein buch war gerade
auf englisch heraus gekommen und ich war
jeden sommer in new york auf werbetour
ich hatte mir vorgenommen mich in einem
konkreten projekt zu engagieren so wie
ich mich schon an der
globalisierungskritischen bewegung im
zusammenhang mit seattle beteiligt hatte
das hat mit meiner herkunft zu tun
mein vater kämpfte in barcelona im
spanischen bürgerkrieg das war teil
meines politischen hintergrund betrachte
mich selbst als anarchist
das ist fast unvermeidlich mein vater
war kein anarchist aber er kämpft den
krieg und wein barcelona während der
revolution und da sammelte er
erfahrungen mit dem prinzip der
selbstverwaltung die meisten leute
finden nicht anna lisa etwas schlechtes
sie finden sie so etwas eher ein
verbranntes sie wurden nie funktionieren
sie ist aber nichts verrücktes sie ist
eine realistische politische position
und in meiner familie gab wenn es
tatsächlich funktionieren würde warum
nicht ein anarchist sei aber aktiv habe
ich mir nie engagiert dann und wann
versuchte ich mich zu beteiligen aber
ich fand nichts was mir passt ich war
eher ein philosophischer anarchist dann
geräte in ein gebiet wo der staat
aufgehört hatte zu existieren
ich arbeite den madagaskar als die
staatsgewalt mehr oder weniger vom land
abgezogen worden war
ich brauchte eine weile bis ich begriff
wir glauben zwar dass wir die polizei
brauchen weil wir sonst einander
umbringen aber die erfahrung beweist
dass das nicht passieren würde
ich war an einem ort in die polizei
verlassen hatte und keiner tötete
jemanden die leute verhielten sich wie
zuvor
sie redeten sich einfach ein dass die
polizei nicht da wählen
das fand ich interessant wenn wir uns
vorstellen wie die menschen unter
gewissen umständen handeln würden und
diese annahme ist falsch was heißt das
was bedeutet es unter der ständigen
drohung von gewalt zu leben so wie es in
unserem rechtssystem der fall ist
es droht uns mit seinen regeln gewalt
und unglauben wird dass wir uns ohne
diese regeln anders verhalten würden was
gar nicht der fall ist das hat mich in
der idee bestärkt dass viele
institutionen gar nicht nötig sind
als ich dann im gefolge von seattle
endlich jene bewegung bildete mit der
ich mich identifizieren konnte schloss
ich nicht ihr an
es waren die demonstrationen gegen die
wto konferenz von 1999 ich hatte davon
nichts gewusst
im vorfeld war davon nichts in den
medien ich kam von einer vorlesung an
der universität von yale ruhig damals
lehrte und seinen kleinen zeitung stand
mit der schlagzeile kriegsrecht in
seattle
da dachte ich kriegsrecht und
tatsächlich fand eine massenaktion zur
verhinderung der ministertreffen der
welthandelsorganisation statt
da waren viele anarchisten dabei ein
befreundeter journalist berichtete für
eine zeitschrift
ich sagte mir als anarchist will ich
wissen wer diese leute sind und was sie
wollen und ich habe mich ihnen
angeschlossen erzählt wie sie
politisiert wurden und wie sie zu dieser
occupy bewegung kommen aber noch einmal
was bedeutet ihnen die bewegung heute
bei war nach meiner auffassung teil von
etwas das als weltrevolution von 2011 in
die geschichte eingehen
das habe ich vom soziologen immelborner
steen wenn wir über weltrevolution reden
so heißt es etwa die französische
revolution habe gar nicht so viel
verändert
dänemark etwa habe sich in den 100
jahren davor und danach mehr verändert
als frankreich den entgegnete dem jedoch
dass die veränderungen dänemark nur
durch die französische revolution
möglich gewesen sei denn jede revolution
sei eine weltrevolution einfach mal
schließt sie die übernahme der
staatsgewalt mit ein wie die
französische oder die russische
revolution und manchmal sind es nur
ereignisse die sich auf die ganze welt
ausbreiten ohne machtübernahme aber mit
tiefgreifenden folgen wie etwa 248 oder
ich glaube 2011 wird in gleicher weise
in erinnerung bleiben
es gab eine welle von bewegungen die vom
nahen osten über südeuropa bis in die
usa hinüber speckte inzwischen ist die
idee der direkten horizontalen
demokratie fast institutionalisiert als
weg auf dem der gesellschaftliche wandel
stattfinden kann
demokratische bewegungen versuchen sich
gar nicht mehr im staat zu integrieren
da sehen wir in brasilien oder in der
türkei
wenn sie an einem ort niedergeprügelt
werden sammeln sie sich an einem anderen
ort wieder
sie sind ein hervorragendes politisches
instrument geworden was sie sagen klingt
alles ziemlich revolutionär vielleicht
auch in tropischen was sie so
interessant macht für viele leute auch
aus gesprächspartner ist dass sie eben
nicht nur wenn man das so nur sagen
möchte in diesen bewegungen aktiv sind
bei occupy aktiv sind sondern eben auch
ein gefeierter forscher sind sie waren
bevor sie jetzt an der
sie unterlagen school of economics eine
professur erhalten haben waren sie in
yale tätig an der universität in yale
sie haben ihren vertrag nicht verlängern
gehalten und man munkelt das sei
geschehen aus politischen motiven hat
sie das damals getroffen
das war ein eigenartiges erlebnis
natürlich wurden mir die gründe nicht
genannt viele meinten hat sein konflikt
wegen einer befristeten anstellung
gewesen aber jeder teilt selten
unbefristete professuren
ich dachte wenn ich keine stelle auf
lebzeiten bekomme ist das auch recht
aber da gab es eine
studentengewerkschaft und in der
universitätsleitung dachten viele ich
wurde damit machen deutlich versuchte
neutral zu bleiben und naiver weise nahm
ich an wenn ich in jeher nicht politisch
aktiv wäre und mich auf meine
aktivitäten in new york beschränkte
würden sie es tolerieren bei ihre
machtposition nicht bedroht wäre
aber sie waren so überzeugt dass sich
die gewerkschaft unterstützte dass sie
meine loyalität auf die probe stellt sie
wollten meinen besten studenten feuern
der ein gewerkschafts aktiv ist war
natürlich habe ich mich für ihn
eingesetzt in diesem sinne war es in der
tat politisch motiviert
sie sagen ja schon insgesamt oder sich
zu zeigen sich insgesamt in diesem buch
kritisch bezüglich schulden sie sagen
auch so etwas wie schulden fast greifen
die menschen tendenziell man kann auch
sagen das wird oft angenommen kredite
sind so etwas wie das schmiermittel der
wirtschaft ohne kredite werden wir nicht
neue investitionen tätigen wenn man sich
ein erfinder denkt dann brauchte er
vielleicht für seine großartige idee
einen kredit um die erfindung dann
umzusetzen in einer maschine
wie stellen sie sich denn die wirtschaft
vor wenn wir jetzt davon abstand nehmen
weiterhin kredite aufzunehmen und
schulden zu machen
es gibt viele wege kredite zu
organisieren ohne verzinsliche darlehen
die geschichte kennt lange perioden mit
dem prinzip des gewinnanteils das
islamische bankwesen versucht nach einem
ähnlichen prinzip zu funktionieren was
allerdings nicht geht wenn es nicht alle
tun
aber es gibt durchaus die möglichkeit
solche arrangements zu treffen was ihr
heute haben war in europa lange zeit
ungesetzliche schon im mittelalter und
zu allen zeiten gab es neue ideen wie
gesagt wäre die gewinnbeteiligung
naheliegend wenn man in ein projekt
investiert bekommt man einen teil des
gewinns an stelle des zinses aber es
gibt auch viele andere wege soziale
kredite zu vergeben volkseigene banken
oder genossenschaften können in ihrem
wirkungskreis große erfolge aufweisen
im neunzehnten jahrhundert gab es viele
experimente auf dem prinzip der
gegenseitigkeit arbeiterorganisationen
versuchten das geld vom zugriff der
banken fernzuhalten
aber sie wurden vielfach mit politischen
mitteln ausgeschaltet und schließlich in
eine größere struktur von finanzkapital
re integriert
ein blick auf die amerikanische
geschichte zeigt dass im 19 jahrhundert
die meisten unternehmen genossenschaften
waren
da das bankensystem aber weitgehend
nicht genossenschaftlich war wandelten
sich in guten zeiten viele
genossenschaften in privatfirmen um
sobald aber eine rezession ausbrach
bekamen die genossenschaften der
arbeiter keine kredite mehr
denn im gegensatz zum privatunternehmer
hatten sie keinen saison auf der bank
es gibt also zahlreiche beispiele für
ein soziales kreditwesen
das problem ist dass diese sehr leicht
wieder zur beute der reichen und
mächtigen wird die es als mittel der
sozialen kontrolle benutzen
wie sich herausgestellt hat wurde vieles
reichlich überschätzt
interessant ist wenn wir für den
zeitraum von 1945 bis etwa 75 das
wachstum des wohlfahrtsstaates
betrachten da gab es eine art
übereinkunft ausgehend von der weißen
oberschicht der nordatlantischen staaten
der die lautete wenn ihr nicht
kommunistisch werden bekommt der
sozialleistungen bildung und ein
gesundheits wings eure kinder sollen
nicht länger arbeiter seien und die
sozialen bewegungen der darauf folgenden
jahre zeigen dass immer mehr menschen an
diesen deal teilhaben wollten die
bürgerrechtsbewegung die minderheiten
die südliche hemisphäre und nicht
zuletzt die frauenbewegung bis zu dem
punkt wo eine art integrations krise
eintritt wo der kapitalismus nicht mehr
für alle einen guten deal bereit hat das
system bricht ein
es gibt eine finanzkrise im
arbeitslosigkeit ökologische
katastrophen szenarien
plötzlich gibt es in den 80er jahren
eine neue verteilung wo es keinen
zusammenhang mehr gibt zwischen
produktivität und löhnen oder
sozialleistungen alle leben auf pump
man sieht dass in den usa da wurden in
den 80er jahren hypotheken die
geldautomaten benutzt jeder mal hatte
sein investitions oder rentenkonto mit
dem er sich ein stückchen vom
kapitalismus kaufen konnte somit der
profit aus einer ausbeutung wenigstens
als kleiner anteil zu ihm zurückfloss
der mikrokredit ist einfach teil dieses
ganzen systems eigentlich sollte er alle
probleme lösen aber es ist erschütternd
dass es aufs gleiche hinausläuft weil
mehr leute daran teilhaben wollen wird
es immer weniger machbar
mikrokredite sind ein desaster
das zeigen die selbst modellen in ganz
indien und bangladesch die letztlich von
ihnen her
denn diesen leuten wurde soziales
vertrauen im hinblick auf ökonomischen
gewinn geschenkt was sie einander
gegenüber verantwortlich macht aber oft
wurde dieses geld zur linderung von not
eingesetzt
statt zur erzielung von profit da diese
kredite an frauen abgegeben werden
bezahlen sie damit auf die schule für
ihre kinder oder gesundheitskosten
sie werden zahlungsunfähig und alle
anderen machen druck auf sie viele
dieser kredite sind ja verbrieft ganz
ähnlich wie subprime-hypotheken da kann
man dann die leute und haben in den
armen dörfern die blechdächer von den
häusern genommen weil jemand seinen
kredit nicht zurückzahlen
man stelle sich vor was da geschehen
konnte wenn eine familie da für alles
verantwortlich betrachtet wurde
da ist vieles ziemlich schief gegangen
bevor diese alternativen greifen können
sagen sie braucht es etwas nämlich einen
schuldenschnitt wir sollten alle
schulden erlassen das ist etwas wofür
sie plädieren sie haben dafür auch
historische vorbilder in ihrem buch
genannt länder wo das regelmäßig gemacht
worden ist in der antike beispielsweise
wir kennen das auch aus der bibel
jedes siebte jahr ist ein sabbatjahr
irgendwie habe ich trotzdem den eindruck
ist das nicht unfair wenn man einfach
alle schulden streicht es gibt staaten
die leben über ihre verhältnisse die
pläne den staatsapparat auf die stecken
unglaublich viel geld in die
rüstungsindustrie in die ganze armee
die bauen sich in welche prachtbauten
lang sollen jetzt die anderen länder
dafür geradestehen
etwas muss man bedenken wenn man darüber
spricht dass länder für die schulden
anderer länder geradestehen müssten
deutschland zum beispiel bringt dieses
argument ständig aber deutschland ist
ein exportorientiertes land
man kann nicht exportorientiert seien
wenn andere länder nicht import
orientiert sind das geht nicht es
braucht beides man kann nicht
exportieren und es nicht akzeptieren
wenn andere diese exportgüter kauf
schuldenerlass heißt je nach land und
situation etwas anderes wir wissen
in einem gewissen ausmaß wird es nötig
sein alle ehrlichen vertreter von
regierungskreisen geben das zu wenn man
sie darauf anspricht
das wirkliche politische ringen wird
darum gehen wie es passieren soll wird
es von politischen basis gruppierungen
wie die occupy-bewegung ausgehen oder
wird es von oben angeordnet werden um
bestehende strukturen der ungleichheit
zu bewahren
ich bin nicht dagegen spezifische
militär schulden aufrecht zu erhalten
griechenland zum beispiel hat die
höchsten militärausgaben innerhalb der
eu während der griechenland krise machte
die türkei das angebot dass beide länder
ihre militär schulden halbieren
das hätte für beide nationen interessant
sein können doch griechenland sagte nein
man muss sich das auch gebe es in meinem
land ein paar kriegsschiffe weniger
könnte ich damit leben
stattdessen lassen sie zu dass alte
menschen und krebs patienten sterben bei
einem falschen ort gespart wird das ist
doch nicht fair aber schauen wir den
schuldenerlass generell an wobei es
nicht um die tilgung der gesamt schulden
eines landes geht die us-regierung will
zum beispiel ganz sicher nicht dass ihre
schulden gestrichen werden
trotz anderweitiger behauptungen will
clinton hat in der 1990 er jahren das
budget ausgeglichen
das versetzte alan greenspan den
damaligen republikanischen vorsitzenden
der us-notenbank in helle panik aus als
ich sagte er wenn wir kein defizit mehr
ausweisen grassiert bei uns der
sozialismus
dann hat die regierung so viel geld dass
sie es ausgeben wird natürlich für dinge
welche die bürger wollen zum beispiel
die krankenvorsorge industrie oder das
bildungssystem das sagte er in der
öffentlichkeit
doch der wahre grund seiner befürchtung
leyen anderen er wusste dass schulden
nötig sind um das geldsystem aufrecht zu
erhalten
denn eigentlich sind die dollar die in
den usa im umlauf sind kriegsschulden
ohne schulden hätten wir gar kein geld
nicht wirklich lustig an diesem buch ist
dass ich es aus der perspektive des
außenseiters geschrieben habe
ich komme aus einer typischen
arbeiterfamilie meine eltern besaßen
nicht mal eine kreditkarte und mein
bruder hatte erst eine in seinen letzten
lebensjahren
ich selbst konnte meinen studien
darlehen zurückzahlen und hatte seither
keine schulden mehr noch einmal über
dieses streichen von schulden
sie machen einen interessanten vergleich
es gibt da diesen vorwurf dass man sagt
okay wir nehmen jetzt eine person eine
studentin ja kein kredit aufgenommen um
ihr studium zu finanzieren davon gibt es
ganz viele leute in den usa viele davon
waren in der occupy-bewegung aktiven
also hoch verschuldet weil sie ein
studium machen wollten jetzt die eine
person pokert einfach und hofft dass die
schulden irgendwann gestrichen werden
die andere person bemüht sich redlich um
diese schulden abzahlen zu können
sie sagen nun wenn ich sage das ist doch
unfair wenn man jetzt einfach die
schulden streicht die eine person hat
sich bemüht die andere nicht dann sagen
sie das ist ungefähr das gleiche wenn
eine person sagen würde der da drüben
wurde opfer eines überfalls war müssen
jedoch aus fair heitz gründen die andere
person auch gleich überfallen
es ist nicht ein bisschen an den haaren
herbeigezogen man kann sich doch schon
vorstellen dass leute gerne möchten was
man sich bemüht kredite abzuzahlen
ich habe das getan ich habe mir meine
studien schulden zurückbezahlt deshalb
fand ich ich könnte das sagen
ich habe jahrelang meine schulden
abgestottert ich will nicht dass andere
das gleiche durchmachen müssen
anders gesagt die einen wollen dass
schuldner wegen ihrer schulden leiden
müssen andere wollen nicht dass
müssen es kommt darauf an wen man
bevorzugt
was ist denn die alternative also wenn
wir jetzt sagen eben vielleicht kann man
schulden erlassen
aber man könnte ja auch sagen ist dort
gar nicht erst zu dieser situation
kommen würden sie denn sagen sollte
keine studiengebühren geben oder einfach
niedrigere studiengebühren die tatsache
dass er unsummen für die bildung
bezahlen müssen die in den usa ist das
eigentliche problem
und das ist nicht die folge irgend einer
unpersönlichen marktlogik obwohl es so
dargestellt wird
wir haben in den usa ein system das wir
von der occupy-bewegung angeprangert
haben in unserem system kontrolliert ein
sehr kleiner prozentsatz der bevölkerung
beide politischen parteien und diese
macht üben sie durch ein wirksames
institutionalisiertes bestechungssystem
aus indem sie die öffentliche
verschuldung perpetuieren das ist
politisches kalkül
es passiert nicht einfach so das tun sie
ständig denn die meisten dieser
unternehmen schaffen die gesetze mit
denen sie reguliert werden sie geben den
politikern geld damit diese gesetze
festlegen und sie durchbringen und fast
ausnahmslos verursachen diese gesetze
eine immer tiefere verschuldung der
bevölkerung
das geht so weit dass schätzungsweise
jede mittelstandsfamilie in den usa bis
zu 40 prozent ihres einkommens direkt
dem finanz- versicherungs- und
immobiliensektor zahlt seine
studiendarlehen hypotheken oder all die
gebühren und bussen die ständig zu
geldtransaktionen hinzu kommen die kaum
jemand wahrnimmt dass es ein massiver
teil des erwerbseinkommens und all das
wurde mit der regierung ausgehandelt
ähnlich ist es mit den kosten für die
bildung die um das fünffache der
inflationsrate gestiegen sind
die genauen zahlen kenne ich nicht aber
sie sind schockiert und das meiste geld
geht ans verwaltungspersonal das
eigentlich nichts tut
denn die lehre verdienen nicht mehr
sondern weniger ihnen geht es mies und
ausbildungssystem wird immer schlechter
und trotzdem teurer
schuld daran ist die verflechtung von
regierung und finanzwesen
das sage ich immer bezüglich der
rückzahlung von darlehen
wir müssen bedenken dass wir den banken
die macht gegeben haben darlehen zu
gewähren
das kann ich nicht genug betonen wir
haben keine ahnung wie das bankwesen
funktioniert henry ford sagte einmal es
ist gut dass die durchschnittsamerikaner
unser bankensystem nicht verstehen
verstünden sie es hätten wir noch vor
morgen von einer revolution
denn jeder meint wenn die bank darlehen
gewährt habe sie das geld von irgendwo
her
die wende eine alte pensionären all ihr
erspartes geben gerade natürlich musst
du es ihr zurückzahlen
sonst steht die alte frau mittellos
nichts könnte der wahrheit ferner seien
95 prozent des geliehenen geldes oder
mehr wird durch den abt der
darlehensgewährung kreiert das meiste
geliehene geld stammt von der
us-notenbank die es geschaffen hat wir
haben also ein monopol geschaffen indem
wir gewissen leuten das alleinige recht
gaben geld herzustellen
das tat mir nicht um sie reich zu machen
sondern damit sie einem sozialen
bedürfnis nachkommen denn wir dachten
ein privates system würde garantieren
dass wir gesünder und gebildeter
wohlhabender und freier wären als ohne
wir geben also unsere geld den
politikern
diese schaffen gesetze die aus uns
gewissermaßen leibeigene machen so dass
wir weniger gesund gebildet wohlhabende
frei sind als ohne
also halten sie sich ganz klar nicht an
ihre verpflichtungen
da frage ich mich warum sollten wir die
ihnen das recht gegeben haben dieses
geld zu schaffen moralisch verpflichtet
seien es zurückzuzahlen obwohl sie auf
ihrem twitter-profil schreiben
danach ist es zeigt eine identität
sondern das sei etwas was man tun würde
was tun sie denn also was tut einfach
ist wie stellen sie sich das vor wie
sollen diese bildungsfragen den
organisieren
bezüglich des anarchismus betone ich
immer wir handeln sowieso fast immer
anarchistisch der anarchismus vertritt
die philosophie dass man den menschen
nicht ständig mit gewalt drohen muss
damit sie vernünftig handeln tatsächlich
handle menschen hauptsächlich deshalb
unvernünftig weil sie bedroht werden
behandelt man erwachsene wie kinder
handeln sie wie kinder oder aus anderen
gründen der ungleichheit oder wegen
sozialer maßnahmen die man nur mit
gewalt durchsetzen kann
dieses system scheint seine eigene
berechtigung zu schaffen doch wenn die
polizei verschwindet verhalten sich die
leute nicht so wie man erwarten würde
ja und zwar gewaltig schuldzuweisung im
wörtlichen sinn
ich nenne da für immer das beispiel
unsere bibliotheken für die
universitätsbibliotheken den usa trifft
das ebenfalls zu angenommen ich möchte
ein buch von foucault ausland das
erklärt warum zwang heute weniger
wichtig ist als mentale selbst ich habe
zwar keinen gültigen studien aus weiß
ich will aber das buch trotzdem ausleihe
und gehe am aufsichtsposten vorbei
doch plötzlich kommen sicherheitsleute
mit stöcken und pistole nacken dich und
entfernen dich vom gelände damit du für
alle ewigkeiten weiß was passiert wenn
du dich nicht ausweisen kannst wir
werden also ständig physisch bedroht
aber es passiert praktisch nie an
jemanden davon abzuhalten gewalt
anzuwenden
denn oft wenn leute aufeinander losgehen
greift die polizei nicht ein
mit der drohung sollen gewisse private
und institutionelle vereinbarungen
durchgesetzt werden und diese maßnahmen
sollten wir nicht wahrnehmen
aber wir begegnen ihnen ständig in
unserem alltag
anarchisten versuchen institutionelle
strukturen zu schaffen die ohne solche
drohungen funktionieren situationen in
denen sich menschen einfach treffen und
sich vernünftig verhalten
sie fragen was ist anarchist ische
praxis nun das was wir beide tun
wir sitzen an diesem tisch und
unterhalten uns etwas das man nicht mit
gewalt durchsetzen muss wenn sich
mehrere leute einigen einen konflikt
bereinigen oder ein problem lösen können
ohne dass sie einen anwalt beiziehen
oder weiter polizei drohen müssen sind
sie anarchisten und wenn leute an einer
bushaltestelle eine warteschlange werden
zwingt sie nun hat dazu das ist
selbstorganisation und darum geht es im
anarchismus menschenhandel meistens
anarchistisch ich würde mich auch hinten
anstellen
beim bus aber es gibt auch andere frauen
ich meine es gibt gewisse prinzipien der
rechtsstaatlichkeit auf die würde ich
nicht verzichten wollen beispielsweise
das recht darauf einen fairen prozess zu
erhalten oder das verbot der folter
prinzipien eines rechtsstaates die will
ich nicht aufgeben wollen wir sollten
die sichern
problematisch an der bekämpfung von
folter ist dass es wenig bringt leute
die am liebsten foltern würden für die
durchsetzung des folterverbots
einzusetzen
ich bringe immer folgendes beispiel die
leute sagen es gibt typen die
schreckliche dinge tun wollen
die wird es immer geben aber unter
anarchisten werden diese sicher nicht
die armee unter sichern
diese menschen wird man sowieso nie
man kann nur eine privatarmee haben wenn
leute als privat soldaten arbeiten
wollen wenn man machtstrukturen hat gibt
es immer leute durch für diese
machtstrukturen zuständig sind
aber es gibt kaum leute die sich diesen
machtstrukturen unterordnen wollen
wenn sie die wahl haben libertäre
anhänger des freien marktes in den usa
vorhersagen sie können mich nicht daran
hindern jemanden anzustellen der meine
tomaten pflückt und ich sage jeweils das
würde ich nie tun
doch keiner sagt sie können mich nicht
daran hindern mich anstellen zu lassen
die tomaten andere zu pflücken
niemand scheint derjenige sein zu wollen
der die tomaten andere pflückt ohne
staatsgewalt gebe es keine niedriglöhne
und somit auch diese radikale vater
unterwerfung nicht menschen tun das nur
wenn sie keine andere wahl ein
interessanter mann aris muss ist ja dass
es eigentlich ein ganz breites spektrum
von politischen positionen abdeckt es
gibt wahrscheinlich gewisse positionen
die würden sie teilen mit der tea party
und es gibt gewisse positionen die sind
ganz links außen wo die die
verantwortung des individuums vielleicht
weniger stark betont wird sondern sehr
viel mehr der gemeinschaft sind betont
wird was ist denn für sie wirklich der
kern des salafismus der kern des
anarchismus ist der widerstand gegen
bürokratischen zwang und die überzeugung
dass menschen vernünftig handeln wenn
man es ihnen ermöglicht viele strukturen
die von uns abgelehnte verhaltensformen
verhindern sollen schaffen diese in
wirklichkeit
ich glaube nicht dass wir so viel mit
der tea party bewegung gemein haben die
gewisse leute meinen markt beziehungen
das ist ein wichtiges argument in meinem
buch sind durch starken geschaffen
worden sowie geld und unpersönliche
märkte geschaffen wurden um armeen zu
finanzieren
in der geschichte der menschheit
entstanden sie parallel zu den
kriegsoperationen generell schafft der
staat durch zwangsmaßnahmen diese art
von kompetitiven märkten
viele meinen diese würden außerhalb des
staates operieren
doch wie die geschichte zeigt ist das
überhaupt nicht der fall
in situationen wo es einen markt gibt
und keine staatlichen zwangsmaßnahmen
verändert sich diese schnell
dann verschwindet das wirtschaftliche
maximierung und bett
das verhalten menschen sind kooperativer
auf der basis von ehrlichkeit und
vertrauen denn es gibt keinen
verdrängungswettbewerb keiner verhindert
dass man dem anderen die kehle
durchschnitten
man muss eine basis des vertrauens
schaffen nicht so handeln wie die
wirtschafts lehrbücher suggerieren sie
haben schon erwähnten der occupy
bewegung geht es darum auch in ihrer
politischen theorie eine horizontale
basisdemokratie aufzubauen horizontal
deswegen weil es eben keine hierarchien
oder nur sehr flache hierarchien geben
soll
in der occupy-bewegung hat man ja auch
so eine ganze reihe von handbewegungen
entwickelt wie man sich einbringen kann
kann ich mal davon vormachen sicher
davon gibt es verschiedene versionen
sie entstammen den weltweiten
gerechtigkeit bewegungen oder in den usa
der anti atomkraft bewegung der 1970 er
jahre
genaugenommen gehen sie sogar zurück bis
in die direktdemokratischen anfänge des
feminismus ende der 60er und anfang der
70er jahre
da gab es diese völlig struktur losen
spontanen treffen überschritten diese
eine bestimmte anzahl menschen braucht
es eine gewisse organisation das was wir
heute als prozessorientierte
organisation bezeichnen ich rede gerne
von fast an arien oder klangen anarchie
dabei waren wir nicht auf unsere
position sondern arbeiten vielmehr
anarchistische prinzipien aus das tun
wir schaffen demokratische prozesse
prozesse also die man nicht mit
zwangsmaßnahmen durchsetzen muss daher
liegt der schwerpunkt auf dem konsens
als anthropologe verstehe ich unter
konsens das was menschen auf der ganzen
welt tun wenn sie kollektive entscheide
treffen müssen aber die minderheit nicht
dazu verdonnern wollen mitzuziehen
viele meinen die demokratie sei in
griechenland geboren worden aber das
stimmt natürlich nicht
auf der ganzen welt trafen menschen
immer wieder kollektive entscheidungen
auf egalitärer basis aber sie stimmt
nicht ab denn wenn man den minderheit
nicht zwingen kann mit zu ziehen wenn
man sicher zuletzt einen öffentlichen
wettkampf in dem einer verliert man will
sie via konsens gewinnen um einen
konsens zu erreichen braucht es einen
prozess in dem ich die spaltungen und
unterschiede betont sondern kreative
synthesen geschaffen werden alle geben
ihren beitrag suchen kompromisse bringen
neue ideen ein
anstatt abzustimmen entwickelt man ideen
weiter bis man etwas findet dass alle
akzeptieren etwas dem die meisten
zustimmen und das niemand total ablehnt
solche gesten dienen dazu diesen prozess
zu beschleunigen
denn man hat ja nicht den ganzen tag
zeit wenn hundert oder sogar tausend
leute versammelt sind und eine
entscheidung treffen sollen kann das
sehr lange dauern
anstatt die hand hoch zu halten und so
zu bekunden dass man einverstanden ist
macht man mit den händen so gewisse
leute sagen dass in stamme der
zeichensprache der amerikanischen
ureinwohner
andere sagen dass stamme aus der
gehörlosen sprache und bedeutet applaus
ich weiß es nicht genau aber bei uns
bedeutet es ich unterstütze diesen
vorstoß und man sieht sofort ob die
meisten dafür oder dagegen sind ohne
dass ihr sagen lassen
manchmal fühlen wir die temperatur wie
wir das nennen jemand schlägt vor
treffen wir uns morgen um 5 was meinen
die anwesenden dazu eine andere so dafür
oder dagegen
und so zeigen sie dass sie unsicher sind
man spürt sofort die stimmung im raum
und gewinnt damit viel zeit wie genau
wie doch zurück zu diesen konsens weil
die idee ist ja schon dass man der
konsens ist sozusagen der moment wo die
entscheidung getroffen ist wenn ein
konsens erreicht hat ist dass das was
man macht und ein stück weit ich ja auch
die idee dass das das richtige ist das
richtige zu tun
aber es gab eine zeit an alles ein
konsens darüber dass beispielsweise in
der schweiz die frauen nicht abstimmen
dürfen das war ein konsens oder es gab
eine zeit eine lange zeit wo man bach
das ist richtig sklaven zu halten
wie können sie garantieren dass der
konsens wirklich dass normativ richtige
ausdrückt beim frauenstimmrecht oder der
sklavenhaltung kann man doch nicht von
ganz entsprechen so etwas kann nur
durchgesetzt werden wenn man menschen
bedroht voraussetzung für einen konsens
hingegen ist dass alle einbezogen und
angehört werden
diesbezüglich muss man sagen dass sich
die haltungen ändern
die quäker pflegenden konsens schon seit
langem für sie ist er ein religiöses
sakrament das im lauf der zeit
weiterentwickelt haben
in einem arbeitsintensiven prozess daher
sind sie allen anderen voraus
die quäker gehören zu den sozial
progressivsten gruppierungen in den usa
konsens findungsprozess können außerhalb
von zwangsmaßnahmen funktionieren
das heißt nicht dass sie nicht auch
missbraucht werden viele unternehmen
werden auf konsens basis geleitet die
meisten japanischen unternehmen und auch
einige amerikanische stark
hierarchischen unternehmen hingegen
setzten konsens manchmal auch als
druckmittel ein
wir sagen nicht es löse alle probleme
aber es ist das einzige system das ohne
zwang gegen eine minderheit
funktionieren kann noch kinder hätten
wie würden sie denn ihre kinder erziehen
wenn sie keine gewalt anwenden möchten
ich kenne viele anarchisten die kinder
haben und natürlich will man seinem kind
möglichst gleiche rechte geben
aber ich sage immer wenn man sich für
gleichberechtigte beziehungen ein
muss man sich auf ebenbürtiger basis
einbringen können
deshalb ist es nicht autoritär kinder
mit zu disziplinieren
denn kinder verhalten sich autoritär
manchmal sind sie kleine diktaturen
sie verstehen nicht immer warum es
falsch ist sich so oder so zu benehmen
insofern man alles daran setzt ihnen das
verständlich zu machen ist man nicht
autoritär sondern antiautoritär gewisse
leute die sind einfach kleine tyrannen
da muss man dann irgendwie auch etwas
entgegenhalten
jedes kind ist mit drei jahren ein
kleiner tyrann das bin ich damit sagen
wenn man älter wird und solche dinge
versteht muss ball verantwortung für
sich übernehmen
lassen sie mich aufhören mit einer
letzten dem der über die ich eigentlich
gerne mit ihnen noch länger sprechen
würde nämlich die idee des
bedingungslosen grundeinkommens gerade
eine große aktualität in der schweiz da
wurde gerade die initiative eingereicht
die initiative sieht vor dass alle
personen in der schweiz 2500 franken
erhalten bedingungslos egal ob sie einer
bezahlten arbeit nachgehen oder nicht
ist das etwas wovon sie sagen das wäre
der idee des anarchismus in die hände
spielen
jetzt bildet werden kontext wird das
wurde in einem gewissen kontext
ausgebrütet mit dem ein
wirtschaftssystem tiefgreifend verändert
werden soll
als konzept gefällt mir diese idee die
initianten wollen damit sagen wenn man
es den individuen über ist was sie zur
gesellschaft beitragen wollen
tun sie meistens etwas dass wertvoller
ist als wenn man sie dazu zwingt denn
menschen wollen grundsätzlich keine
parasiten seien einige wenige vielleicht
schon aber nicht so viele dass sie
wirklich schaden anrichten können
mir gefällt dass beispiele gefängnis
auch in hochsicherheitsgefängnissen
werden insassen relativ gut behandelt
man gibt ihnen essen und unterkunft ihre
grundbedürfnisse sind gedeckt ihre
strafe besteht darin dass sie nicht
arbeiten dürfen jeder will doch arbeiten
und etwas aus seinem leben machen und
viele leute kreieren dinge die man nicht
für möglich halten würde
ich lebe momentan in london haben sie
gemerkt dass dort kaum neue bands
entstehen früher entstand dort
großartige musik fragt man die leute
deshalb nicht mehr sagen sie wegen der
arbeits bestimmungen für erwachsene gebe
diese bands bezieht sozialhilfe
doch auf jeden jugendlichen der nichts
aus seinem leben macht sich nur zudröhnt
das leben genießt gibt es einen oder
zwei die eine band gründen und
großartiges vollbringen das kann man
nicht vorhersehen
wenn man menschen machen lässt kreieren
sie manchmal dinge die andere sich nie
erträumt hätten und dadurch wird die
gesellschaft bereichert
[Musik]
wenn sie mehr über david gray erfahren
möchten gehen sie online auf unserer
kultur plattform finden sie einen
spannenden artikel dazu die dvd dieses
gesprächs können sie wie immer bestellen
bei schweizer radio und fernsehen
redaktions sternstunden 80 52 zürich
ihre e mail erreichte uns unter stern
kopien hat srf punkt ch werden uns
roboter immer ähnlicher und wenn ja was
heißt das für uns die menschen
nächste woche gehen wir diesen und
anderen fragen nach in der srf
themenwoche roboter wie wir für die
sternstunden hat baarer bleisch den tanz
humanisten nick bostrom eingeladen und
spricht mit ihm über unsere zukunft im
zusammenspiel mit robotern ganz und gar
menschlich aber wird jetzt um zwar mit
einem großen künstler
er ist ein meister der erzählkunst
raffiniert verbindet irving in seinen
werken fantasie und wirklichkeit ein
film
[Musik]